und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend wer sich in diesen tagen
fragt und wo bleibt das positive muss
wohl das fernglas rausholen irgendwo am
horizont winken massen von impfdosen und
ein ende des kronacher dieses ende wird
kommen und es dauert nur leider noch und
so fällt es aktuell etwas schwer noch
gute laune zu bewahren
angesichts abgesagter osterferien und
der aussicht auf erneut schließenden
museen läden und schulen wobei da noch
nicht ganz klar ist wie sich das im
einzelnen gestalten wird im einzelnen
ist dabei wörtlich zu nehmen die
einzelnen bundesländer machen ja
bekanntlich mehr oder weniger ihr
eigenes ding
einiges soll aber für alle gelten
gründonnerstag als zusätzlicher feiertag
der nur nicht so heißt
ostergottesdienste sollen bundesweit
möglichst nicht stattfinden und hotels
für touristen nirgendwo öffnen
außer auf mallorca aber dazu kommen wir
später noch erstmal berichtet britta
spiekermann über die ergebnisse der
gestrigen marathon-verhandlungen und die
reaktionen darauf
die nacht ist schon fast tag als bund
und länder ihren beschluss in die
öffentlichkeit tragen notbremse war eine
instituts über 100 und vollbremsung über
ostern um die dritte infektionswelle wie
es heißt zu brechen und deshalb sollen
der erste april gründonnerstag also und
der dritte april einmalig als ruhetage
definiert werden mit weitgehenden
kontakt beschränkungen sowie ein
sammlungsverbot vom ersten bis fünften
april deutschland soll rund um ostern
noch stiller stehen als ohnehin schon
reisen nur wenn zwingend notwendig
familie nur im kleinsten kreis es nagt
mehr als zweifel an denen die man fragt
jetzt spielen sie ostereier zu ich finde
tragbar mittlerweile ja es frustriert
einfach immer dasselbe
es geht immer weiter ich hoffe
jedenfalls dass
naroska und die 14 tage danach eine
besserung eintritt so dass wir eine
gewisse normalität mal wieder erreichen
eine gewisse normalität gibt es im
moment noch wenn die incidents stabil
unter 100 liegt es darf mit termin
eingekauft werden aber rund um ostern
ist auch damit schluss der handel
kritisierte bund und länder agierten nur
noch im tunnel modus ohne weitsicht
die heute noch sehr kontraproduktiv aus
die infektionsketten und das
infektionsgeschehen alle triftigen
gründe was doch zu schließen und damit
den ganzen oster einkauf auf mittwoch
und samstag zu konzentrieren dann sind
so viele leute unterwegs das ist nicht
gerade sinnvoll die politische
verteidigungsrede kommt aus bayern der
stadt daun sei alternativlos bildhaft
umschrieben wie gewohnt die stimmung ist
ungefähr wie momentes wetter leicht
depressiv vieles in resignativ es gibt
aber keine möglichkeit der situation
auszureichen
die lage ist ernst und sie wird noch
sehr viel ernster werden
die wahrheit ist auch es fehlt an tests
die notbremse also vor allem eine
notlösung nochmal ganz erheblich
aufzubauen so dass man nach den
ostertagen in der lage ist eben ganz
massiv mit den testungen voranzutreiben
bund und länder hätten versagt bei
impfungen und bei tests
diese schutzmaßnahmen dafür hat die
bundesregierung die verantwortung der
sie nicht gerecht wird
die regierung muss ich doch mal darüber
gedanken machen ob sie irgendetwas neu
und besser machen kann was wir jetzt
erleben dass die bürgerinnen und
bürgerinnen und bürger für einbußen
erleben die sind auf die monatelange das
monatelange versagen der bundesregierung
zurückzuführen
eigentlich war auch eine allgemeine
nächtliche ausgangssperre geplant
bundesweit wird sie nicht kommen länder
regionen entscheiden nach lage berlin
hat bereits abgewunken ein solcher
grundrechtseingriff sei zu
tief dass sich die runde gestern bei der
feriengestaltung besonders verhakte ist
nicht verwunderlich
alle ministerpräsidenten und
präsidentinnen wissen was sie ihren
wählern damit antun
die osterferien praktisch abzusagen
erzeugt gewaltigen frust und
neiddebatten etwa wenn die nachbarn sich
zum urlaub an die holländische küste
verabschieden oder in den flieger nach
mallorca steigen
hier hat man selbst nicht ins gebuchte
ferienhaus auf rügen darf interessant
ist in dem zusammenhang übrigens auch
dass die ausgangssperren die im gespräch
waren hierzulande enorme empörung
auslösen dass es exakt solche
ausgangssperren auf mallorca gibt
scheint aber niemanden abzuhalten
im mediterran im setting er trägt sich
das ja vielleicht auch besser und mit
logik darf man es in dieser pandemie
wohl eher nicht zu genau nehmen in
vieler hinsicht welche reise regeln
jetzt gelten erklärt dominik
löschmeister prost auf den insel urlaub
deutsche touristen auf mallorca
sie genießen abwechslung vom corona
alltag in deutschland
das ist sehr korrekt und läuft alles
vernünftig ab jetzt in deutschland so
ablaufen würde hätten wir da auch
weniger zahlen
rund 40.000 deutsche sind in diesen
tagen nach mallorca geflogen die
balearen kein risikogebiet mehr den
festland spanien dagegen ist urlaub auf
den spanischen inseln verwehrt wie hier
in madrid dürfen sie bis zum 19 april
nicht raus aus der region in der sie
leben
ich finde das nicht korrekt ich kann
nirgendwohin fahren nicht mal meine
familie sehen
jeder sollte in diesen tagen vorsichtig
sein
jetzt ist einfach nicht der moment
seinen wohnort zu verlassen und zu
reisen
selbst den briten ist mallorca verboten
umgerechnet fast 6000 euro strafe drohen
allen die vor ende juni ins ausland
reisen deutsche dürfen reisen sollen
jetzt aber vor der rückkehr zu einem
corona test verpflichtet werden der
reiseverband begrüßt das weil das noch
mal die sicherheit natürlich der gäste
und auch der bevölkerung insgesamt
wir gehen davon aus dass das eine
regelung ist die in dieser etwas
aufgeregten zeit dann auch begrenzt ist
auf die osterzeit während den ausland
übernachten möglich ist bleiben im
inland hotels auch an ostern für
touristen geschlossen
zwar gibt es kein generelles reiseverbot
doch das im ausland mehr möglich ist als
im inland bringt die politik in
argumentationsnotstand sinn einer
eindämmung der pandemie sein dass die
leute nach
jetzt da massenweise in den urlaub
fliegen das sind alles schwerst
vermittelbare dinge um es mal vorsichtig
auszudrücken
gegenüber der bevölkerung denn im inland
gibt es zu ostern beschränkungen maximal
fünf personen aus zwei haushalten können
zusammen kommen kinder bis 14 jahren
nicht mitgezählt einige länder wollen in
gegenden mit mehr als 100 neuinfektionen
100.000 einwohnern treffen nur mit einer
einzigen weiteren person erlauben auch
übernachtungen in einer ferienwohnung
darf es nicht geben obwohl sich urlauber
hier abschotten können
zur feier die mit ihrem mann am chiemsee
ferienwohnungen vermietet versteht das
nicht
man schüttet er nur noch den glaubt man
es hat keine logik nennt sich zu hause
könnte man jeden kontakt nachvollziehen
kann eben gast auch mal locker kann ich
das nicht so zeigt sich am beispiel
mallorca das problem der deutschen
pandemie politik widersprüche die nicht
gerade mehr vertrauen bringen
das gefühl in einer dauerschleife
gefangen zu sein kommt nicht von
ungefähr
rund ein jahr ist es jetzt her dass wir
zum ersten mal in einen shutdown ging
manchmal ist es ja gut dass man nicht
immer weiß was so alles auf einen
zukommt hätte man uns im märz 2020
gesagt ach und übrigens im märz 2021
machen wir das immer noch wäre das von
kaum erträglich gewesen
so handelte man sich von monat zu monat
durch das gros naja und hinter jeder
neuen kurve dehnten sich neue
unendlichkeit unendlich fühlt es sich
vor allem für all jene
die ihren beruf nicht mehr ausüben oder
ihr geschäft nicht mehr betreiben
konnten alexander schmidt hat mit drei
betroffenen gesprochen
die erzählen wie sie durch dieses jahr
gekommen sind und wie sie ihre
lebenswege zwangsläufig in andere
richtungen lenken mussten immerhin ihr
online geschäft läuft sind der ba coni
hat aus ihrem café in berlin kreuzberg
inzwischen ein lager gemacht verschickt
von dort aus café süßes und
badutensilien nur der kleine tresen fürs
showgeschäft erinnert noch an die zeit
vor corinna ihr zweites café in berlin
mitte hat sie nach dem ersten lockdown
sofort geschlossen
ein schritt der welt hat nach 23 jahren
jetzt schaut die amerikanerin nach vorn
verdient auch geld mit digitalen bei
kursen um es mal ein und macht die beste
entscheidung stellt es nachher nicht in
frage und wahllos damit auch martin
wimmer hat sich schnell entschieden die
geschäft für bademode und unterwäsche
hat sie bereits im vergangenen sommer
aufgegeben
vermietet die räume jetzt an einen pizza
lieferdienste wenn ich die bilder sehe
ist steckt ein bisschen sehnsucht oder
wehmut dahinter weil ich das geschäft an
sich schön fand von der lage von von der
ausstattung aber jetzt ist es wie es ist
und eigentlich bin ich ja froh ihre ware
konnte sie noch mit gewinn verkaufen
anders als viele andere modehändler und
sie trägt keine verantwortung mehr
arbeitet jetzt als angestellte zwei tage
pro woche in einem modegeschäft in
potsdam
ich musste natürlich erst mal hier in
diese rolle reinwachsen wieder
arbeitnehmer zu sein ich war es gewohnt
entscheidungen zu treffen und die
spontan auch daniela mann und ihre
schwester haben eigentlich immer selbst
entschieden der reisebüro in
berlin-hohenschönhausen lief gut 20
jahre lang vergangenes jahr verloren sie
95 prozent ihres umsatzes und sind
seitdem abhängig von staatshilfen
die sind teilweise so komplex in ihrer
dass man die beantragen kann überhaupt
also wir sind inzwischen ein halbes
steuerberater alle zwei drei tage
erinnerten sich die bedingung zu diesen
hilfen willi beantragt werden können und
jetzt darf das doch eingenommen werden
und das muss jetzt wieder raus gerechnet
werden inzwischen belegen sie
fortbildung um die anträge stellen zu
können
doch ohne diese sofort und
überbrückungshilfen wäre ihr geschäft
längst dicht 37.000 euro flossen bislang
und der dritte hilfsantrag läuft bereits
sie hoffen dass es im sommer wieder
aufwärts geht und sich wirklich jeden
tag aufzuraffen herzukommen und wieder
zu stornieren und sich zum zehnten mal
um eine buchung oder umbuchung zu
kümmern macht mürbe auf dauer also man
ist hammer müde kann es hier wahrlich
nachfüllen diese müdigkeit
schaut man allerdings ins ausland haben
wir eben auch in den berichten gesehen
sind die maßnahmen vielerorts noch
härter als bei uns zum neuen shutter und
der dritten welle jetzt ein kommentar
von redaktionsleiter des heute-journals
beschließen
es gibt keine lockerungen hat jemand
ernsthaft mit etwas anderem gerechnet
was hätten die ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten mit der
kanzlerin sonst beschließen können jetzt
schlagen alle auf den föderalismus ein
aber der ist nicht gescheitert der
funktioniert wie der gemeinsame
beschluss ja zeigt und die handelnden
politikerinnen und politiker sind auch
keine versager sondern sie kämpfen gegen
montierende viren die sich rasend
schnell ausbreiten
sie kämpfen allerdings mit immer noch
wahrlich altertümlichen mitteln
kontaktverbot und masten was beginn der
pandemie einleuchtete wirkt in der
endlosschleife nur noch hilflos denn es
gibt ihn doch längst den retten den
impfstoff nur haben wir nicht genug
davon hier lag das versagen deutschland
der mächtigste mitgliedsstaat der eu in
dem auch noch der beste impfstoff
entwickelt worden ist hätte die
eu-kommission zum viel größeren einkauf
drängen müssen für dieses versäumnis
bezahlen wir nun alle
aber die lager erschien im spätsommer
als der impfstoff bestellt wurde eben
nicht dramatisch genug deutschland hatte
fast die geringsten todeszahlen in der
eu und hat sie übrigens immer noch
trotzdem ist eile geboten und zwar nicht
nur im kampf gegen das virus sondern vor
allem gegen die verdrossenheit des
volkes das vor erschöpfung von der fahne
zu gehen droht jeder impfstoff der taugt
muss her keine dosis darf übrigbleiben
prioritätenlisten müssen
zusammengestrichen und jede arztpraxis
sollte beliefert werden
die regierung muss sich auf die große
mehrheit der impfwilligen konzentrieren
das alte leben kommt nicht durch
öffnungen mit ständigen tests zurück
sondern nur durch impfung in drei wochen
werden die regierenden wieder beraten
ihr gesunkenes ansehen und vor allem
unser aller stimmung kann dann nur eines
heben die impfwelle wolf schließen
kommentierte viele informationen zu
kroner beschlüssen und auch kritik daran
finden sie bei uns natürlich auch online
auf zdf.de und jetzt macht erstmal heinz
wolf weiter mit anderen nachrichten
fünf tage nachdem das missbrauchs
gutachten des erzbistums köln
vorgestellt worden ist hat kardinal
woelki eigene versäumnisse eingeräumt
einen rücktritt lehnte er aber ab zur
begründung sagte er in köln
das ist mir zu einfach und in meinen
augen ist es auch falsch denn die
probleme würden nach meinem weggang
bleiben so ein rücktritt wäre nur ein
symbol des höchstens für eine kurze zeit
hält ich werde moralische verantwortung
sehr wohl annehmen und wahrnehmen
die usa erneuern ihre kritik an der
ostsee gaspipeline nord stream zwei
außenminister blinken forderte einen
stopp des projektes das erdgas von
russland nach deutschland befördern soll
präsident biden habe deutlich gemacht
dass er die pipeline für eine schlechte
idee halte für europa und für die usa
sagte bänken am rande eines nato
außenministertreffens in brüssel
bei diesem zweitägigen treffen ging es
heute vor allem um das weitere
engagement in afghanistan
die usa haben darüber laut blinken noch
nicht entschieden für
bundesaußenminister mars kommt es auch
auf den fortgang der
friedensverhandlungen in afghanistan an
nach einer schießerei im us-bundesstaat
colorado hat präsident beiden erneut auf
eine verschärfung der waffengesetze
gedrängt man müsse handeln um leben zu
retten so biden
bei dem angriff in einem supermarkt und
bürger waren gestern zehn menschen
getötet worden darunter ein polizist der
tatverdächtige wurde bei einem
schusswechsel mit der polizei verletzt
und anschließend festgenommen
nach auskunft seiner familie leidet er
unter psychischen problemen
im prozess um einen tödlichen
raserunfall in münchen ist ein
36-jähriger mann zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt worden wegen mordes
versuchten mordes und weiterer delikte
im november 2009 10 war der mann auf der
flucht vor der polizei mit mehr als 120
kilometern in der stunde in eine gruppe
jugendlicher gerast
ein 14 jähriger starb eine 16 jährige
wurde schwer verletzt der jetzt
verurteilte fahrer hatte am tag der tat
gekokst und getrunken dann impfen sind
die israel ist zwar weltmeister eine
politische krise haben sie aber trotzdem
auch wenn premier benjamin netanyahu
pluspunkte sammeln konnte
mit seinem beherzten im programm aber
das verschaffte ihnen bei den
parlamentswahlen heute in israel keine
sichere ausgangsposition gut möglich
dass die regierungsbildung danach wieder
äusserst schwierig wird und bald darauf
die nächste koalition zerbricht
wir schauen gleich nochmal auf aktuelle
prognosen aber zunächst ein kurzer
bericht unseres korrespondenten michael
bewerunge zur politischen lage in israel
die erste prognose nach der wahl nicht
völlig unerwartet
benjamin netanjahu deutlich vor
herausforderer yapi spannende er die
weiteren plätze
wer hat mehr der anti oder der pro
netanjahu blog das ergebnis denkbar
knapp der netanya block rechts kommt auf
53 knesset sitze mit den acht stimmen
der rechtskonservativen limina würde es
zur hauchdünnen mehrheit von 61 knesset
sitze reichen
kein wirklich klares ergebnis aber auf
der wahlparty des likud in jerusalem
erfreute gesichter
das ist ein großer erfolg nach
monatelanger harter arbeit das volk hat
sich für den enormen einsatz des
ministerpräsidenten für die korona
impfungen und die friedensverträge
bedankt erst vor einer stunde haben die
wahllokale geschlossen der anderen hier
in tel aviv groß auch wenn die
wahlbeteiligung insgesamt etwas geringer
ausfiel als vor einem jahr
es stört mich dass wir in kurzer zeit so
oft wählen mussten aber ich hoffe dass
dieses mal vorläufig das letzte mal sein
wird
ich denke nicht dass jemand anders uns
so führen kann wie bibi
ich sehe niemanden der das besser kann
als bibi netanjahu zeigt sich am wahltag
siegessicher er weiß je stärker sein
liegt desto schwieriger die bildung
einer koalition gegen ihn und appelliert
bis zuletzt an seine wähler bleibt nicht
zu hause
geht wählen ihr könnt ruhig an den
strand gehen und party machen aber
zuallererst geht will rapid sein
herausforderer von der zukunftspartei
spricht von einer schicksalswahl
dies ist der moment der wahrheit für
israel
am ende gibt es zwei optionen und zwar
nur diese zwei entweder eine starke
zukunfts partei oder eine regierung der
finsternis des rassismus und der
homophobie staatspräsident rivlin warnte
heute seit der staatsgründung habe sich
israel noch nie in einer solchen
politischen krise befunden
ob das gespaltene land mit einem so
knappen ergebnis aus der krise findet
steht dahin
dann schalten dann noch kurz nach tel
aviv zu michael bewerunge michael gibt
es jetzt am späteren abend noch mal
aktuelle zahlen oder irgendwelche
verschiebungen
ja wo wenige minuten
wie wackelig so eine prognose ist zeigt
sich gerade einer der großen sender hat
gerade das verhältnis von 61 mehrheit
auf 60 zu 60 der beiden blöcke
korrigiert also eine pattsituation
aktuell aber auch das ist noch lange
nicht ausgezählt stehen noch viele
briefwähler aus dessen diesmal deutlich
mehr so dass man eigentlich erst am
freitag mit einem dauerhaften
endergebnis rechnen wird außerdem steht
die zustimmung von nach der die bälle
daraus für emina der seine acht sitze
netanyahu zu schreiben muss das hat er
angekündigt und er hat sich auch schon
aktuell geäußert und gesagt er tue das
was gut für israel ist was wohl
übersetzt bedeutet er will seinen preis
vorhanden
interessant ist an dieser wahl insgesamt
dass es doch eine starke polarisierung
gibt vor allem die parteien am rechten
und linken rand haben gewordene also die
religiösen zionisten zum beispiel und
das ist kein gutes zeichen für das land
insgesamt muss man sagen ist die
sowohl nach rechts gerückt und es ist ja
auch schon die vierte wahl innerhalb von
zwei jahren dankeschön michael für diese
informationen direkt aus tel aviv und
jetzt nochmal eins zunächst mit dem
blick auf die deutsche wirtschaft und
zwar auf die autobranche
denn heute abend war auto gipfel mit
bundeskanzlerin merkel und vertretern
der branche sowie aus den bundesländern
valerie haller gibt es schon ergebnisse
ja es gibt ergebnisse die sind gerade
erst herausgekommen druckfrisch
sozusagen ja im kern geht es ja darum
wieder abschied vom verbrennungsmotor
gelingen kann ohne dabei arbeitsplätze
und wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu gefährden
die eu plant schärfere klimaziele bis
20.30 für die deutsche autoindustrie
wird es extrem schwer
die vorgaben einzuhalten einziger ausweg
derzeit mehr e mobilität da hapert es
noch an einigen stellen und dort setzten
auch die beschlüsse an
der bund will die lade infrastruktur
weiter ausbauen mit 5,5 milliarden euro
außerdem soll es mehr förderung für
ladestationen zuhause geben und die
autoindustrie plan schon nächstes jahr
erst der anwendungen beim autonomen
fahren im regelbetrieb einzuführen
die e mobilität kommt langsam in fahrt
im vergangenen dezember waren über 26
prozent der neuzulassungen schon e
fahrzeuge allerdings inklusive der
umstrittenen plugins die neben der
batterie auch ein verbrenner motor unter
der haube haben schon im vorfeld das
auto gipfels hatte die branche zugesagt
mehr als 150 milliarden euro in den
kommenden jahren zu investieren
in e mobilität digitalisierung und neue
antriebe
nicht zuletzt ging es auch um einen
milliardenschweren zukunftsfonds für die
automobilindustrie wohin das geld
allerdings fließen soll soll erst im
sommer geklärt werden
valerie haller vielen dank der
europäische gerichtshof hat die rechte
von fluggästen gestärkt wenn ein flug
wegen eines angekündigten streiks
gestrichen oder deutlich verspätet sei
könne der kunde ein recht auf
entschädigung haben so der bgh in seinem
urteil
die fluggesellschaft könne nicht
argumentieren dass es sich um einen
außergewöhnlichen umstand handel
nach einer reihe von niederlagen in der
bundesliga europa league und dem
dfb-pokal trennt sich bayer leverkusen
von trainer peter bosch auf ihn folgt
zunächst hannes wolf der bis jetzt die
u18 nationalmannschaft trainierte ob die
zusammenarbeit auch nach saisonende
fortgesetzt wird ist derzeit aber noch
offen
die deutsche fußball nationalmannschaft
bereitet sich auf ihr ist das wm
qualifikationsspiel übermorgen gegen
island vor heute war erstes trennen
schlechte nachrichten ein trio fällt aus
wegen muskulären problemen müssen niklas
süle und robin goossens kürzer treten
schlimmer hat es toni kroos erwischt der
wegen leistenschmerzen zurück nach
spanien reist wieder mitwirken kann
dagegen josua kimmig sein kollege vom fc
bayern manuel neuer wünscht läuft zum
abschied einen titel
ich denke dass wir diese erfolgreiche
ehre auch mit dem schönen abschluss
krönen wollen wir wollen ihm denke ich
auch ein großes geschenk machen nur mit
drei überzeugenden auftritten können sie
sich rückenwind für die em holen motto
verlieren verboten
thomas mann hatte davos vor augen als er
seinen berühmten zauberberg schritt
heute denkt man bei da wo es eher
angehobenen wintersport oder ans nicht
weniger elitäre weltwirtschaftsforum
dabei gibt es durchaus eine historische
linie von thomas manns lungen sanatorium
über skifahren bis zum internationalen
stelldichein wichtiger menschen und es
gibt eine parallele zu heute um die
leidige corona pandemie noch mal zu
erwähnen
zu zeiten des zauberbergs grassierte
auch eine solche die bekämpfung der
sogenannten schwindsucht liest davos zum
welt kurt r blühen dieser
bemerkenswerten entwicklung widmet sich
aktuell eine ausstellung im germanischen
nationalmuseum in nürnberg
annegret oster hat sie sich angesehen
auf den ersten blick ist diese
ausstellung
ein sammelsurium werbeplakate neben
spuck näpfen das grammophon von ernst
ludwig kirchner die tagebücher von
thomas mann persönliche visitenkarten
die von menschen und ihren welten
erzählen was europäische kultur bedeuten
könnte an einem ganz kleinen ort war
dieser ort davos ist ja nur ein
brennglas indem wir größere
zusammenhänge besser verstehen weil wir
sie reduzieren kann auch weniger
personen als in berlin oder paris wo
ähnliche entwicklungen stattgefunden
haben und das ist das was uns
interessiert das leben in seiner ganzen
spannbreite zu zeigen und auch die
kontraste die tuberkulose macht mitte
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts aus dem
kleinen berg bauerndorf einen hotspot
der internationalen high society jungen
heilanstalten schießen aus dem boden
zehntausende gut betuchte patienten
pilgern jedes jahr nach davos erhoffen
sich mit liege kuren heilung von der
lungenkrankheit
wer dazugehören will reist hierher
parallel dazu entwickelt sich der
skisport in der sport war sicherlich
nicht das was auf dem plan stand als man
tuberkulose krank nach davos reist aber
kranke reisten häufig nicht allein
brachten verwandtschaft und freunde mit
oder wurden auch besucht und für die
musste auch etwas geboten werden
davos zieht schließlich alle an sportler
künstler schriftsteller aus sport wird
expressionistische kunst ein besuch
seiner frau katja im wald sanatorium für
thomas mann die inspiration für seinen
zauberberg davos wird zum
kristallisationspunkt der die umbrüche
der moderne deutlich macht wir
betrachten die zeit der moderne von 18
70 bis etwa 1940 und stellen fest dass
der blick auf die gleichen dinge
unglaublich contra ist und das
entspricht eigentlich unserer heutigen
wahrnehmung wir blicken auf das gleiche
wir diskutieren das gleiche aber die
wahrnehmung die wertung ist komplett
unterschiedlich erst 1943 mit der
erfindung von streptomycin und die
tuberkulose gut behandelbar aus den
heilanstalten werden hotels und aus dem
luftkurort wird eine sport hochburg wo
man um preise und medaillen ringt
aus dieser konfrontation mit einer
unwägbaren situation kranksein man weiß
nicht ob man es überlebt ist literatur
entstanden ist kunst entstanden ist
sport entstanden das was wir die
europäische kultur nennen und ich glaube
das ist das was uns heute unglaublich
schwer fällt was machen wir mit diesem
cockpit lassen wir uns nur zurückwerfen
oder gibt es kompensationsmöglichkeiten
mit dieser bedrohung des menschlichen
lebens umzugehen und das ist die kultur
kunst und kultur als widerstandskraft
und als möglichkeit mit leid und
krankheit umzugehen wie man das tut
bleibt jedem betrachter selbst
überlassen so viel vom heute schon mal
heute ist übrigens welttag der
meteorologie der sich in diesem jahr
speziell den ozean widmet und welche
wirkung die weltmeere auf wetter und
klima haben erklärt gleich es den termin
nach dem wetter geht es weiter mit der
reportage reihe 37° heute zum thema
hausbau mit der traum vom eigenheim zum
alptraum werden kann und um 0.15 gibt's
dann unser heutigen update mit einer
sand guckte mir und einem gespräch mit
li zweite hat uns geht es morgen wieder
zu sehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute ist welttag der
meteorologie oder schauen wir in diesem
jahr auf die ozeane die klima und wetter
beeinflussen
bei uns vor allem die atlantic
zirkulation zu der auch der golfstrom
gehört ohne sie wäre es bei uns im
schnitt fünf bis zehn grad kälter
und so funktioniert sie salziges wasser
ist generell schwerer als süßwasser
kühlt sich das salzige wasser aus dem
süden im norden ab wird es noch schwerer
sinkt ab und strömt in zwei bis drei
kilometer tiefe zurück nach süden ein
natürliches förderband das problem durch
die erhitzung schmilzt zunehmend das
meereis und es regnet mehr
das senkt den salzgehalt und bremst den
strom nach einer aktuellen studie ist er
so schwach wie seit 1000 jahren nicht
das wirkt auf die atmosphäre und
begünstigt extremwetter indirekt auch
bei uns in deutschland aber auch die
wärme energie in den ozean spielt eine
rolle und die nimmt seit dem jahr 2000
deutlich zu man sieht es hier in
hellblau dass es die tiefe bis 700 meter
und in dunkelblau von 700 bis 2000 meter
tiefe was man generell erkennt die wärme
energie nimmt weiter zu
und das wirkt sich aufs wetter aus wir
schauen aufs wetter im nordosten
deutschlands viele wolken in der nacht
im südwesten klart es auf temperaturen
minus sechs bis plus sechs grad und
morgen gibt es vor allem im süden viel
sonnenschein nach norden müssen ist es
deutlich bewölkt aber trocken und das
bei temperaturen von bis zu 16 grad im
südwesten deutschlands und 8 grad ganz
im norden die kommenden tage am
donnerstag wird es trocken sein bei
werten bis 16 grad freitag kommt etwas
ring von nordwesten her auf und damit
ein schöner abend